DANNY HERMES: I specialize in
the Shopping APIs, the Content
and Search APIs for Shopping.
And today, like we do every
other week, we'll be talking
about the Content API
for Shopping.
I have here with me one of
our more significant--
not more significant,
more vocal--
community members,
Andrew Lamonica.
And we're going to be recapping
I/O, talking a bit
about some library changes,
and then reviewing a new
change to the API, a new feature
that was added since
our last Hangout.
So first let's talk about I/O.
So I have some things I want
to show you.
So if you go to
developers.google.com, we have
all the event data from every
talk that was at I/O, but in
particular the two
talks we gave.
So we gave a talk--
myself and our product manager,
Mayuresh Saoji--
gave a talk on making Product
Search, or making Google
Shopping, work for you using
the Content API.
And as you can see here, this
is at developers.googl
e.com/events/io/
sessions/gooio2012/400.
Our talk was title 400.
Excuse me, it was number 400.
And on this page, we
have a YouTube
video of the talk itself.
So if you want to watch
the talk in its
entirety, you're free to.
We have the abstract.
We have some headshots, if
you miss seeing my mug.
And we also have the slides.
Don't want to do that.
So here you see my slide that
can actually be viewed.
So I'll go over a few
highlights from that
talk in a short bit.
But I also want to emphasize
the other talk we gave.
We talked about empowering Local
Shopping through Google
Product Search or through
Google Shopping.
This was not myself but
two of our wonderful
engineers from Zurich.
The video, again, in this link--
the talk was number 401
rather than 400, but all the
rest of the link is the same.
Their presentation can also
be retrieved as a PDF.
My presentation was
an HTML5 deck.
So you can actually see it the
same way it was presented.
And of course, there's some
headshots and an abstract, as
well, before you get into it.
So before I talk about my talk,
a bit about theirs.
They talked about how you can
set up a Google Places account
to actually have local product
data associated with your
Google Merchant Center
account.
And then from there, they used
the Content API to insert an
item with channel equals
local rather than
channel equals online.
And then they used the inventory
feed, which is one
of our feeds other than the
products feeds, to actually
insert item data for particular
stores associated
with the Places account
they created.
It's a pretty interesting
use case.
For people who are interested in
setting up a Local Shopping
account, they have contact
information towards the end of
their video for who within
Google you can contact for
getting that set up.
So for my talk, some of the
things I talked about that I
want to review.
The first thing we talked about
was the Debug dashboard.
And this was a dashboard that
allows you to review errors
with your products
after the fact.
So if you have an insert that
fails or an update that fails
or a delete that fails using the
Content API, then you'll
get the response immediately.
But if you don't log that, then
the response just goes
away when the process with the
RAM that's holding that
response dies.
It just gives the memory back
to your machine, right?
So if for some reason you're not
saving that, persistently,
locally, and you have a huge
spike in errors and you want
to find out what happened, you
can use the Debug dashboard to
actually determine
what happened.
Another thing that
we discussed--
something which we hadn't really
had a whole lot of
fanfare on the launch-- was
the Data Quality API.
And that API is another
service, just like the
Inventory service or the
Products service that I've
already discussed today, as
well as the Multi-Client
Account service that people
are familiar with.
But the Data Quality service
within the API will actually
allow you to get the same data
quality report that you can
get in the Merchant
Center dashboard.
And this is really great for
things like updating certain
information, if you have
price discrepancies or
other things like that.
So I highly encourage either
checking out the deck or
watching the slides or both.
So there are two other things
I want to discuss before I
open the floor for questions
from Andrew.
From what I hear, he doesn't
necessarily have any questions.
But two other things
I want to discuss--
oh, Caroline's here.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Caroline's
here.
DANNY HERMES: Wonderful.
One of our .net library
users is here.
And she'll be happy to
hear the next thing I
was going to announce.
In the weeks leading up to I/O,
as well as the week after
I/O, I was able to write some
patches for the four services
that we were missing
that are offered
within the Content API.
So we had implemented, prior
to Google I/O, the Products
service, which is the main one
you're using, as well as the
Manage Accounts service.
And in addition, we
also implemented
the four other services.
So there's the User Feed, which
allows you to determine
the users associated with a
particular Merchant Center
account, as well as to change
permissions, to add new users,
or to remove users from
a particular account.
This is particularly
relevant for people
who use managed accounts.
Because if they're creating a
new sub-account for one of
their clients, and maybe they
want their clients to be able
to see the data within that
sub-account, they can
programmatically add
those accounts--
or excuse me, they can add those
users to that account
using the user's API.
So we've added that service.
In addition, we've added
the Data Quality API.
This is something Caroline
personally asked for in one of
our previous Hangouts.
So we've implemented a
particular function within our
Content API service which
allows for this.
In addition, we have
implemented--
what are the other services?
We've implemented the Inventory
service, which is
what you'll be using
for Local Shopping.
And finally, we have
implemented--
it's just on the tip
of my tongue.
What is the fourth service?
So I can't think of
it right now.
Let me just go to our
documentation and just find
out what it's called.
So I'm navigating to
our wonderful Docs,
developers.googl
e.com/shopping-content.
So we have the inventory feed.
We have the users feed.
We have-- ah, of course.
The data feeds feed.
So this is a feed which has been
around a long time but
isn't necessarily used too
much by our developers.
But it allows you to set up
scheduling for data feeds
files through the API.
Now, this sort of contradicts
our best practices.
But some people who are mixing
and matching data feeds with
the API can actually find
this feature useful.
So we implemented those four
services in addition to the
two that were existing.
Now, we didn't have anyone
request it, but we also
implemented these in the
Python client library.
And I'm currently wrapping up
the additions to our PHP
client library.
So people who are wanting to
access services other than the
Multi-Client Account service
and other than the Product
service will actually
be able to,
using our client libraries.
So Caroline, do you have any
particular questions about
these implementations?
Have you had a chance to look
at them, before I move on to
the third and final talking
point I have?
CAROLINE: I have not had a
chance to look at them.
So I'll have to do that.
Sorry.
DANNY HERMES: No, no.
It's no worries.
They were a single commit
for each service.
So we had four commits.
And I think they're all at the
head or the tip of the SVN
repository.
And then I don't know if there's
been a release yet.
I'm pretty sure there was a
release after the fourth
commit, because it was
so much new code.
But I have a seat right next
to the maintainer of the
library now.
I just moved my seat recently.
And I was able to poke and prod
him after I/O, to say,
hey, here's my commits.
Can you get them in?
And can you release
it quickly?
So like we discussed in early
June or maybe late May, you
wanted support for the
Data Quality API.
Well, now we have it.
So I hope you use it.
I hope you find the API
within the service
object easy to use.
If not, I greatly encourage
you to tell me what I did
wrong and how it
can be better.
Because I'm happy to
make those changes.
CAROLINE: Awesome.
Thanks.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
And so the final thing I wanted
to talk about today is
some updates we made.
I'll need a new tab for this.
Some updates we made to the
Manage Accounts feed.
And this is particularly
relevant given some of the
changes that were announced
recently around the move to
associating with AdWords product
listing ads campaigns.
So within the Multi-Client
Accounts feed, which I will go
to in a second, we have added
the ability to associate an
account with an AdWords
account.
So we've just added a
sub-attribute within the SC
namespace called
adwords_accounts.
And using this, you can have
child elements, which are at
the attribute adwords_account--
not accounts, the singular
rather than the plural.
Again, in the SC namespace.
And you can say whether that
account is active or inactive.
And then, of course, the value
of these XML attributes will
just be the AdWords
account ID.
And an AdWords account ID is a
10-word ID with three digits
separated by a hyphen, and three
more digits separated by
a hyphen, and then the
final four digits.
So a bit about using this.
So this obviously needs to be
used with the MCA feed, the
Manage Accounts feed.
So for someone who doesn't use
Multi-Client Accounts, they
won't be able to use the API
to associate a particular
sub-account with an
AdWords account--
a sub-account within
the Merchant Center
account, that is.
And the logic behind this is,
if you're not using a
Multi-Client Account, then
chances are going through the
settings through the actual
Merchant Center probably is
not as difficult.
But if you're managing thousands
or tens of thousands
or even just tens of accounts,
going through the Merchant
Center and doing these AdWords
accounts associations by hand,
for even 10 accounts, is
probably not going to
be worth it, right?
So a little bit about
how this works.
If you currently don't have any
AdWords account associated
with your account, or if you
create a new account and you
don't send AdWords accounts,
what you'll get in the
response is just an empty
AdWords accounts link.
And if you send in an insert
request or in an update
request, if you send an empty
AdWords Accounts link, it'll
actually delete any
association--
excuse me, not an AdWords
Accounts link.
An AdWords Accounts
XML element.
If you send an empty XML AdWords
Accounts element, then
it will actually delete any
associations you have.
However, if you don't send any
AdWords Accounts element, it
won't make any changes to
your existing account.
But it will return an element
that has the current list.
So it will always be
in the response.
But it's not required to
be in the request.
And the reason is for backwards
compatibility,
people who have implementations
which aren't
sending the element, we don't
want them to leave it out and
then either A, cause an error
in their feed, or B,
accidentally delete
associations they
didn't mean to delete.
So that kind of describes the
functionality of that.
Do either of you have
any questions?
Andrew, we discussed
a little bit before
we started the Hangout.
I figured you may have
some questions after
I demoed this feature.
But I wasn't sure if
it was interesting
enough for you to care.
Because I know you guys aren't
using Multi-Client Accounts.
ANDREW LAMONICA: We don't really
have enough to do that.
But I may use the GET portion
to provide some extra
functionality to our
internal tools.
Because marketing is a different
department than
engineering.
I think the biggest problem
we have with
AdWords right now is--
or at least the biggest
questions we have are related
to how the URLs are going to be
handled post-migration to
Google Shopping.
Because we're going to want to
make sure that our tracking is
online on day one.
And right now, we send different
tracking codes
through the different URLs.
There's One for Google Shopping,
one for AdWords.
Is there any news on that yet?
DANNY HERMES: No news yet.
I haven't heard a whole lot.
The team is working every day,
obviously, to try to figure
out the best way to
do this migration.
And when we know more,
we're certainly going
to write about it.
We'll blog about it.
We'll update our Docs,
et cetera.
Your question, in particular,
I'm going to ask the team
about, ask what the plans
are, and see if
we can get an answer.
If we can, I'll post
it to the forum.
And maybe we can discuss it in
our next Hangout two weeks
from today.
But if not, I'll try to give you
an update on the timeline
on when we will know.
And by the way, our next Hangout
is going to be two
weeks from today.
So that'll be July 33, or August
2 for those who are
using calendars like
normal people.
Caroline, do you have any
questions, as well?
And also, Andrew, if you have
other questions that you want
to see answered about the
migration, beyond URLs and
things like that, feel free.
I'll be able to use
this video.
I'm not taking notes
right now.
But I can take notes after the
fact and take those questions
back to the appropriate teams.
So Caroline, do you have
any questions?
CAROLINE: I do not.
I've actually been pushed
onto a different project
temporarily.
So I'm just trying to
keep up with things
until we return back.
So you know how it goes.
DANNY HERMES: Sure, sure.
ANDREW LAMONICA: I do have--
I will make my--
I think I've made this
in the past.
But I'll make it
one more time.
DANNY HERMES: Please do.
Please do.
ANDREW LAMONICA: My push
for a feature request.
It would be great if we could
get impressions data back on
the individual products.
DANNY HERMES: Yes, yes.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Because we're
trying to pick what products
we're going to want to really
feature in the new world.
DANNY HERMES: So nothing
to announce right now.
But keep your eyes peeled.
Andrew and I actually discussed
this at I/O, in person.
He was one of our guests.
So it was actually great
to see him in person.
And it is a feature that we've
seen asked for quite a bit.
And it is something that we're
trying to figure out the best
way to implement.
Like I said, nothing to
announce right now.
But keep your eyes peeled on the
commerce blog and on the
forum and other places.
By the way, Caroline, thanks
for coming to the Hangout,
given the fact that you're
not actively working on
implementation right now.
It's great to have you as a part
of the community still.
CAROLINE: And I only missed
the last two.
Because one I was on vacation.
And then one I forgot you
switched till Tuesday and I
was like, oh no!
DANNY HERMES: So there wasn't
one since the Tuesday one,
because of I/O. We sort
of had a big hiatus.
CAROLINE: Sweet.
DANNY HERMES: So you've
only missed one.
CAROLINE: That's exciting.
I'm feeling good.
DANNY HERMES: So Andrew, I think
I've taken sufficient
mental notes.
I don't think I need to actually
go back and watch the
video after the fact.
You want to know two things.
How are we going to be handling
URLs for these campaigns?
And when--
or if-- are we going to get
impressions data with the SC
performance block that we get
back when we make GET requests
for particular items specifying
performance start
and performance end, which is
a great feature if people
aren't using it, which maybe
we'll talk about in a Hangout
in the future.
OK, guys.
If you don't have any other
questions, we'll wrap up and
we'll see you July 33.
August 2, that is, for people
who want me to be correct.
ANDREW LAMONICA: All right.
Thanks, Danny.
DANNY HERMES: All righty.
CAROLINE: Sounds great.
Thanks, Dan.
DANNY HERMES: See you guys.
CAROLINE: Bye.
DANNY HERMES: Cool.